[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
9-1-1 calls released in the murder
double homicide murder mystery
the herring pleas for help as a father
in a prominent south carolina family
says he found his wife and son dead the
police
can't just immediately my wife and tom
and celebrity chef mara batali and his
former business partner to pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars
to victims of sexual harassment plus
changes made after the tragic murder of
a college student how samantha josephson
murder led to a new law
and rocked a college town we were scared
to leave our rooms
later a rough rescue as firefighters
hammer away
to save a trap pup it was like she
wanted to be
saved she wanted to come to that wall
and survivors describe having flashbacks
to a triple shooting that left one man
dead
and two others injured what he did goes
beyond shame
beyond her approach beyond his dignity
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
two celebrity restaurateurs ordered to
pay six hundred thousand dollars
after an investigation revealed numerous
incidents of sexual harassment at their
businesses
new york state's attorney general
announcing friday mario batelli
joseph bastianich and their management
company will fork over the money to at
least 20 former employees
the ag previously revealed details of
the probe that found incidents of sexual
discrimination and retaliation
including managers favoring men over
women and making misogynistic comments
a former line cook at the now closed
eatery del posto saying this in a
statement
when my female co-workers and i were
being sexually harassed by multiple
people at del posto
the restaurant's leadership made us feel
as if we were asking for it as if it was
a rite of passage to be harassed at work
sexual harassment discrimination and
retaliation should never be normalized
in any industry or workplace
this settlement is an important step in
holding the powerful
accountable joining us today is criminal
defense attorney bernardo villalona and
terry austin
bernard the dollar amount 600 000 for
around
20 people so about 30 000 per victim
does that seem like a slap on the wrist
or a serious punishment
not at all it's definitely a serious
punishment and why do i say it's a
serious punishment because
number one they're being held
accountable to begin with
so being held accountable plus the
dollar amount sends a message out
to these different businesses that
sexual harassment will not be tolerated
here in new york
now terry on the other end of this
settlement what do you think of the part
uh where the culture of these
restaurants have to change and be
monitored
brian i've always thought that it was
important in any sexual harassment
settlement
to have training as part of that
settlement
because that's when you're going to
change the culture when you think about
it
employees spend about a third of their
lives at
work and it's important that they feel
valued that they feel
included that they feel as though their
thoughts
are something that are important to the
employee and employers and other people
at the company so
i think it's very important the only
thing that's really going to change the
behavior is not the money
that the company has to pay but it will
be the changing of the entire culture so
it's very important
yeah so the money kind of taking care of
the past incidences
and the changing of culture and ensuring
that the future we're not here again
talking about uh these restaurants thank
you both
turning now to south carolina where
officials have released the 911 calls
from a murder mystery involving a
well-known family in legal circles
i think the police immediately my wife
and tom
a startling 911 call on an early june
night in rural south carolina
the father of a prominent family frantic
after he said he drove up to his house
to find his wife and son shot and
motionless
is he breathing at all no no
is she okay do you see anything
do you see anyone in the area no ma'am
alex murdoch says his wife maggie and 22
year old son paul
were shot near pet kennels on the
property i don't know if you've already
touched them but i don't want you to
touch them just in case they can get any
kind of evidence okay
i already touched them trying to get
to see if they were breathing no one has
been charged the murdoch family is sadly
no stranger to tragedy
the son paul was due to go on trial
charged in the boating death of a 19
year old girl
in 2019. he was caught on surveillance
taking two shots of liquor before
crashing a family-owned boat
into the pilings of a bridge alex's
father randolph iii
died days after the recent double murder
randolph murdoch along with alex's
grandfather and great grandfather
all served as the top prosecutor of four
counties in the lower south carolina
samantha josephson's murder in south
carolina rocked the community and
spurred changes in ride sharing
law and crime's angela levy spoke with a
woman who was in college in colombia
when this all happened
yeah brian ordering an uberero lift has
really become
second nature to a lot of people
following samantha josephson's murder
a law was implemented in new jersey to
make ride sharing safer for passengers
and college students across the country
and in south carolina changed what they
did when going out at night
new jersey has taken the lead to help
make the rideshare industry
safer samantha josephson's parents
pushed for changes after their
daughter's murder
in their home state of new jersey sami's
law required ride share companies to
provide
additional identifying markers to
drivers
after the beautiful coed was killed
after getting into what she believed was
an
uber near the university of south
carolina
as leaders it is our greatest
responsibility
to ensure the public safety and to
implement smart policies to prevent
tragedies
josephson's murder also changed the way
her fellow college students went out at
night
i would say the biggest change that
happened
is everyone's awareness of their
surroundings
kelsey shallowness was in the popular
five points area the same night
josephson was killed
she recalls being scared to go out after
the murder but calls the what's my name
campaign
launched by josephson's family a silver
lining that came out of the tragedy
i know a lot of my friends said that
when they would go
up to their uber drivers because uber i
mean everyone was
ubering everywhere every single day
and a lot of my friends would go to
their uber drivers and say
you know hey are you for kelsey for
example
now a federal version of sami's law that
passed in new jersey
passed in the u.s house last year it
then moved on to the senate
where no legislative action was taken
brian
thank you for the update uh and jeanette
and of course remember the what's my
name
hashtag to ensure safety when we're
going through rideshare
still ahead on law and crime daily more
on samantha's case and the man
now on trial for her murder we take you
inside the courtroom
and later the georgia attorney convicted
of shooting his wife in their suv
will tex macgyver get a new trial stay
with us
[Music]
welcome back we're following the south
carolina trial of a man accused of
murdering a college student who
allegedly got into his car
thinking it was her uber ride
prosecutors asked the defendant's
ex-girlfriend
if she's ever seen him with the believed
murder weapon
the little is something you can use to
open something but
like i'm sorry i can't really describe
it
i'd like to show you something that's
been marked to stay together over 225
is this something that you've seen
before
not exactly that but
something like that
use it to open something i mean that's
it
on cross-examination the defense asked
if she knew
other people had driven the defendant's
vehicle
maybe i know his cousin
we'll maybe go to the store but not
really no
no okay um you went to
his parents house you said yeah i've
been before
to his sister's house yeah y'all would
hang out at the house you'd spend time
together
you would go to the five points area but
you said it wasn't that frequent right
not not that many times okay so that was
not the normal
hangout and they were gonna go do
something let's go to five points yeah
okay
and how did you say how long the
relationship was
it was maybe four months i want to say
but it wasn't
long let's bring back criminal defense
attorney bernardo villalona and terry
austin to discuss
terry the direct is just the building
blocks of the prosecutor's summation so
what can we gather that the prosecution
will argue after this witness
you know i think they're going to argue
a few points brian there's no question
that maria
howard established the fact that there
was blood
in the car she asked the defendant about
the blood
and he told her to mind her own business
that was very credible
she also recalled that there were bloody
clothes
of the victim behind her house and i
think that too was extremely important
and i think one of the other things that
the prosecution is going to argue
is the fact that he goes down to the
five points area
very often and he thought it was quote
unquote lit
so i think that's important too the
prosecution is going to say
all of these things and as you heard she
actually did see
something that looked like a knife or a
letter opener
and that's important as well absolutely
now just to clarify maria howard is the
first ex-girlfriend we've seen multiple
ex-girlfriends
uh testify on the stand in this case
bernardo the short relationship between
this ex-girlfriend and roland did that
create any doubt that someone else may
have had access to the car
no not at all because even though it was
just four months remember it is four
months we're talking about 120 days that
this woman had a relationship
with nathaniel roland so she's able to
provide so much
insight as to nathaniel roland and is
able to provide
items that were already corroborated in
the sense of
the blood inside of the car in regards
to the clothing that was fine
found behind the dump truck uh by her
house so all of this is corroborated and
we also think
regardless there's still video
surveillance that shows the vehicle
going around that block a couple of
times before picking up the victim in
this case
absolutely we're seeing brick by brick
by brick by brick being built upon the
prosecution's case
almost making an airtight argument here
we'll of course follow this case
on the law and crime network to see how
the defense combats that as they
progress
thank you both coming up on law and
crime daily hear from the prosecutor
of the black widow murderer about a
deadly love plot plus
the tales one lucky pooch could tell how
firefighters in ohio save the dog stuck
between a rock and a hard place more on
the rough rescue
next
[Music]
we're back firefighters and an alert
neighbor reunite a missing dog with its
owner
and it's all caught on camera internet
levy is here with the amazing rescue
story anjanet
brian this sweet dog was missing for
five days and i spoke with one of the
firefighters who
helped rescue the pup
firefighter jen atkins was on a mission
last weekend
hammering at a cinderblock wall in
search of a dog
i am a dog mom i was like we have to
find her i'm not sure what part of this
garage what part of the wall she's in
atkins and her co-workers were called to
the garage after a woman heard a dog
crying
that dog gerdy had been missing for five
days her owner had fliers posted
throughout the neighborhood
after minutes of hammering jen atkins
saw gertie
and pulled her to safety it was like she
wanted to be
saved she wanted to come to that wall as
soon as there was enough room
she knew it she was trying to squeeze as
much as she could her little chunky self
was coming through that wall no matter
no matter what it was all in a day's
work
as adkins reunited gertie with her owner
now firefighters actually believe that
kurt gerde got into the house through
the attic because there is a hill behind
the home
that is close to the roof so maybe she
crawled in and then fell through a
crevice
in the attic in between the cinder block
walls
uh thankfully though she is safe tonight
they think she was in there
let's get this they think she was in
there most of the time she was missing
so it's really nice to see her reunited
with her owner
poor gertie great to see her back with
her family and hopefully we can
cover that hole up so she's not falling
anymore thanks andrew great
the prosecutor of the so-called black
widow is telling all
on the latest episode of the podcast
cocktails she revealed the cold and
calculated way the infamous convicted
murderer
plotted her husband's killing to our
very own sean stakes larkin
she literally sat there and had dinner
with this guy with her husband
knowing that when he left the restaurant
he'd be killed right
very cold and calculating and when they
left the restaurant
uh he was approached by the person that
had been hired
alex and was beaten to death
um with a brick
oh god wow that's personal on the head
and what is really truly dramatic and
sad
is that when he was being beaten to
death
and she stood by right she he actually
yelled to her run baby run
a former georgia attorney convicted of
murdering his wife
was denied a new trial but as jesse
weber host of the law and crime show
prime crime reveals
there's more to the story
hey there brian yeah it's the tex
mchiver case a prominent atlanta lawyer
shoots and kills his wife in the back
seat of a moving car
but the bizarre nature of this shooting
begs the question is this an
accident or murder we really get into
the evidence and of course we have to
talk about texas
own words from his police interrogation
tape
immediately called out i said everybody
all right and
dan joe said yes and diane
it was kind of slanted and she said
i've been shot worse than that effect
and i immediately put my arms around her
and try to determine
what was how bad it was but brian it's
the verdict that has left people divided
did the jury make the right decision
tune in
to law and crime thanks jesse whoever
make sure to check in and see if it's
accident
or murder and if the jury got it right
make sure to check out prime crime with
jesse weber
when we come back a sentencing of a man
who killed his ex-girlfriend's father
shot her and another innocent man the
surviving victim's heartbreaking apology
next
welcome back a wisconsin man convicted
of killing his ex-girlfriend's father
and two other people was sentenced to
spend the rest of his life in prison
without the possibility of parole a jury
found joshua aide guilty of the murder
of james grootner and attempted murder
of his ex-girlfriend rebecca brokowski
and family friend john miller on the
stand aide said he acted in self-defense
and that the three people he shot were
trying to kill him
but prosecutors said aide was upset
miller was helping fix the car
aid owned with rebecca and wanted to get
revenge on her
the victims asked the judge to sentence
the defendant to the maximum
on august 4th 2020 the defendant
permanently tore my life apart robbed me
of my world and stripped me of my
happiness my hopes
and the dreams jim and i had as
retirement was approaching for
him on that day the defendant
murdered my husband shot my daughter
and shot john miller
there's no way anyone can ever prepare
themselves for this
i stand before you today a broken person
who has lost every sense of normalty
your honor i feel
embarrassed disgusted and ashamed
i think i should have died that night
instead of my dad
i am responsible for bringing this
unlawful being
into my life into my family
excuse me into my family's life
i don't i not always live with that
regret every single day
to my entire family but especially to my
mom
i am sorry beyond words
before he was officially sentenced the
defendant gave a few short words
still not accepting responsibility for
his actions
before sentencing um yes genre on the
night of october 4th 2020 i did not
travel to oshkosh wisconsin with the
intentions to harm anyone you're on
that's it all the victims in this case
were good people
i guess this falls under the heading of
no good deed goes unpunished
rebecca you do not need to blame
yourself
you have zero responsibility for this
i have no doubt in my mind that given
the chance of being released
he would manipulate the system and seek
revenge on every single person who
i had it again he thinks wronged him
as far as gravity of defense you killed
somebody and you tried to kill two more
you had three head shots congratulations
the military taught you well and your
turn to say you have no
you hope here's the hope for you
that your soul doesn't burn in hell for
eternity
now there were a lot of powerful words
shared in those victim impact statements
from the judge the victim and
kind of the defendant there as well from
both of you i'm curious whose words
stood out the most and
do you think they shaped the judge's
decision or was this the sentence all
along
bernardo let's start with you i think
this was definitely the sentence that
the judge had
in mind all along from when the trial
actually started not something that was
determined after he was found guilty
because regardless no matter how many
years you give a person
you're not going to be able to get the
life of a loved one back
however a sentence like this will give
some kind of solace to that family
that the person that took away your
dad's life
is now going to spend the rest of their
life in jail
for me the moving statement was from
rebecca because rebecca she
just feels so guilty and it's something
that it looks like she's going to live
with for the rest of her life she's not
forgiving herself
but she needs to remember that she
didn't make this guy
kill her father and shoot to other
people
let's hope the words of the judge help
give a little solace to rebecca as he
said it's not your fault
terry same question as to the words uh
were they impactful and do they
affect the sentence in any way brian i
agree
wholeheartedly with bernard here there
is no question that
because rebecca feels guilty about
bringing this monster into her family's
life
she feels as though she's responsible
and
i also think the other most powerful
statement was the judge
he said that here the defendant took two
or three
head shots and he ended up killing one
person and that that military training
came into play that was very powerful
and because of that
i do think the judge made up his mind
before he actually heard the statements
i think he read the papers i think he
saw the serious
vicious nature of this crime and i think
he decided i'm going for the maximum
here which is exactly what he did
well done absolutely and there was no
love loss as he was talking about bernie
and helen and all the other notes that
you heard
there um bernard terry as always it's a
pleasure and thank you for joining us
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice
in america
[Music]
[Music]
you